welcome to this video when new part of
the endgame basics and theory series and
in this part we're going to look at the
end games without pawns where the rook
is fighting against the knight or Bishop
a single night or a single Bishop pretty
simple looking position and never that
has a very relevant position it comes up
very often in games where everything is
sort of simplified and the defending
side is just barely escaping to this and
still needs to to draw this means that
normally the night the the lone Knight
and the lone Bishop should drawn against
the rook however very often both night
and king or king and Bishop in the other
case need to be coordinated correctly
they need to be together and work
together to really secure the draw here
we can see a situation where despite
black being on the edge of the board he
cannot be mated by white white cannot
force win black always has enough
defensive resources let's say a tribe as
white to to break through will see that
black always has enough to defend King
f6 advancing and black can give this
check that's absolutely necessary there
is no other move you know something like
this runs into a typical Zuke's one no
black must move the King and gives up
the night
so there is only Knight h7 check in the
herbs in the check in the initial
position here King to g6 and black again
gives the check yeah King f6 is only a
perpetual
so king h6 is the next tribe yeah here
it's easy black only has one move King
edge 8 it looks a bit terrifying but
there is simply no way through a move
like King we aid is answered but King g8
of course and here black will even
escape from the side of the board or
after after Luke is 7 it's a perpetual
check a perpetual of a repetition of the
position sorry
so King edge 8 must be played and is
sufficient rook f7 so further tribe and
now King g8 need to go back
note that this move after Luke f6 loses
yeah you can still make mistakes
especially with little time on the clock
now the knight must move and then rouga
8 made this coming King g8 is right
keeping both pieces together and this
already shows that there is no big way
forward any rook move on the 7th rank
black is just going to play King g8 so
maybe rook g1 trying to block here on
the G file then black is moving the
Knight to d7 he can go to h7 but this is
not a very good choice after King g8
he's in slight trouble to put it mildly
something like this does not end very
well the problem is what should like
play now he is very close to being Zeus
want King h8 king f7 is losing and yeah
there is only this check but then I have
6 check him after rook T 2 leads to big
trouble rook T 2 is taking the square
way and now we have a very problematic
situation for black cupboard cupboard
and also indirectly comic because of
ruke h2
yeah black IAM has has no defense and
something like this it's again leading
through this super Swank position where
the knight is lost it is always a bit
tricky can easily go wrong this is also
the reason why this endgame is very
often lost in practical games when there
is a little time on the clock here 97
must be played to avoid this rook e1 and
9 f8 it's um it's really tough to give a
rule of thumb
how exactly like should defend you need
to be cautious all the time against all
those little tries that the attacking
side has it's very important to keep
Knight and King together and then try to
to calculate all possible lines it will
be tricky with little time definitely
but objectively speaking it is a draw
with enough time like should draw
however as mentioned if white or the
attacking site why does wrong expression
the tacking side is managing to somehow
separate separate King at night it can
be tricky we can now look at a position
where the separation is in fact
happening yeah yes the second position
um in this position black to move he
only has not have to check of course
if with the colors reversed it is much
easier then King f3 just wins very
easily widest and a black isn't a super
smart so Knight F to check yeah King F 3
and now we see the problem in this
position in this position black only has
93 he needs to go away now I cannot keep
the night near the king after 9h 152
it's a Dukes one yeah this is checkmate
direct made
and otherwise the night is lost and
where else I mean here yeah just wins
wins the night or gets the check made in
so there is only this 93 move and this
is clearly in a way in the wrong
direction you have don't have any choice
but it's a it's not very helpful to get
away from from the old king now white
plays the move rook a for taking away
squares from the night before for
example and also intending to give this
cheque at the right moment 95 is played
it's very difficult to suggest something
else what should what should like black
do here for example night be - well this
is check yeah picks up the night the
King also does not have any any useful
move this one needs to made on a1 next
it's a very super smart out of position
this is also not helping
yep like this check mate and the night
hangs this is the big problem once those
pieces are separated there will always
be a combination of an attack against
the night and the meeting Adam Knight c5
is the toughest toughest tribe crew k1
check King age to group t1 taking away
again taking away squares from the night
it's not necessary to sort of learn this
by heart but it's it's about the methods
if you have this position with the rook
should always try to make sure that the
knight is not coming back to the King to
get coordination but try to keep the
defending night away from the king and
try to combine made threats with the
threats against them against this this
lone piece we see that after 96 rooty to
check check kg 1 if black goes to h3
there is rook d6 yeah attending this
maid check
the night distract yeah the lone knight
is strapped it can only go to the age
file and then gets into a deadly pin
this is another way to win this trapping
the night so King to g1 g2 g3 made
threat king F 1 ruble d5 again taking
away lots of squares of the night night
c7 rupee 5 yeah setting up a barrier
this night cannot move Knight to 8 only
move king of three yeah I note that now
if the knight moves somewhere we have
this one again mate and attack on the
night
so King g1 Jack check him King edge to
check again check and repeated here we
have this typical idea mate and the
knight is attacked this is the general
ways to try to win this if the knight
and King are separated you combine those
ideas King on the side of the board
mating ideas and the tank on the lone
Knight it's about temple moves trapping
the night and setting up this favor of
the zoom swung situations we can look at
another example in this position it is
white smooth and here black has
fianchetto night and wait night on b7
and it turns out that this is a very
specific unlucky position where blanc is
in fact losing those pieces are
coordinated they are near each other
but they're not in a very lucky
situation at the
let's see how it unfolds rook t1 a very
logical move taking away the squares no
blacks night cannot move king bed and
now very strong moves is the King to a6
King b6 however which looks a fairly
normal after King c8 it's not enough to
win here black can probably also get the
knight to the eight next and get out of
this King a6 it is in fact much stronger
now after King c7 looks very normal
there is oxygen to be eight would be one
ya winning the night don't forget about
this stalemate yeah so it's not that
easy but King b6 is in fact him winning
quite easily again this idea to to win
the night and now we can come from this
side and have this rook a one maid idea
and this is oops this is killing black
checkmate so at the start of all this
King c7 does not help he probably has to
try this check 95 check King b6 Knight
e4 check check
King c6 Knight c3 no rook to e1 we have
again managed to separate those two
pieces this is the unlucky thing about
the starting position
the pieces are knew each other but they
know don't coordinate well and actually
what managers do to separate them and
now yes as the winning hand
King to s7 Ruby 391 do you 3 9f to check
check and again it's this typical idea
the knight hangs and the mate it's again
not necessary to learn this thing here
especially by heart but it's important
to note that the key points if Knight
and King are separated
very often the tacking side can win if
you defend you need to keep those two
pieces coordinated and and make sure
that they are not they're not separated
by any any tricks
okay this was rook against Knight next
rook against bishop yeah rook against
them and on bishop this is in fact much
easier than the situation with a long
night it is very useful to remember that
the defending side should try to get to
something like this the King in the
corner with the bishop near it so on the
opposite color of the bishop this is a
very easy draw in fact if we look at
this specific position with black to
move did I set this from black to move I
don't think so like to move the key
point is stalemate you know King b6
check check
Asaph dissipate and the only way really
to to go forward would be something like
this Stanley but this is still made and
this stalemate trick always saves the
day so if you reach the corners the
defender of the other color and the
bishop the defense will be very easy
however it can happen that this is not
possible
still you should draw but in the other
corner it is much much more difficult
let's have a look at this situation yeah
here we have a situation where blacks
King is in the wrong corner the corner
of the bishop with the black to move did
I set this correctly seems tough to do
with black to move I really don't have a
defensive this is in fact a lost
position we can look how it is how it is
finished bishop g1 for example a weak f1
should be aged two three push up g3 note
that if black is retreating somewhere
else let's say he goes here then white
will play this move and now black will
get into terminal oops one or is mated
immediately Bishop d7 as the toughest
one covering d8 and then yeah rook d7 is
oh this is in fact not the best move
from sorry rook c1 is better to get to
c8 yes I was in the wrong wrong line in
my notes
rook c1 is right getting rook c8 in the
key point is that something like this is
not saving checkmate yeah this is not
this is simply not a stalemate if it
would be in the corner on age 800 this
is a stalemate but here you you don't
have it so if we go back the bishop must
go here it's the the toughest
fans group 83 Bishop d6 group D 3 and
veneering the winning idea Bishop e7 and
rooks III yeah rook c8 is coming in the
same thing that we had before only here
on the on the 3rd rank this is the big
problem the stalemate defense here is
not working as you have this Square
still on h8 there are still enough
drawing possibilities but right here we
have come to such an unlucky spot that
black is losing so the defending side
should always try to and get to the to
the other corner the corner that is not
of the bishops color if you start this
endgame in a situation where you're in
the middle of the board it is easy to
just head to this corner but sometimes
the Sun arises from a more complicated
situation like from from from position
where silver pawns on the board and then
you actually only get to this position
right here when you are in the wrong
corner then it might be lost so your
level of cautiousness should rise
exponentially if you're in the wrong
corner and this can easily easily be
lost and definitely white northern
usually it is white in those examples
with with the rook the attacking side
should of course always try and try to
play on and win as you always have
practical chances of course the
situation where the King is already in
the right corners it's totally hopeless
but if you have them somewhere else it's
always completely ok to continue in term
and try to try to win ok I hope you
enjoyed those those basic end games look
against the single minor piece if you
want to to practice this and also
improve your ability there too to play
the right moves with real time I suggest
that you maybe
sum-sum computer program and play
against the computer the computer will
definitely defend super tenaciously so
you can compare your work in defense
with the computers moves and also try to
defend against the computer view if you
manage try if you manage so I hope you
enjoyed it
thanks for watching